The Great Depression was a dramatic worldwide economic calamity...
...which started in 1929 and lasted until the late 30s.
Most people believed it begun with the US stock market collapse of October 1929.
By 1932, US stocks were only worth 20% of what they were prior to the crisis.
And one year later, almost half of all United States banks had failed.
Worldwide trade was devastated by the Great Depression,...
...with countries engaging in so-called "trade wars" by limiting imports...
...and by the same year 1932, global trade crashed to half of the precrisis volume.
Unfortunately, trade wars degenerated into an actual armed conflict,...
...which caused over 60 million deaths, World War II.
Make no mistake, most wars have been caused by economic factors to a very large degree.
Let's learn from the past and not let this happen again.